we're gonna we're gonna be friends you
think so we're gonna be friends do you
get that sense
yes no bit
no bit
a little bit
for the rest of the segment just real
serious friend talk
this is gonna be terrible tv
i'm okay with it if it ends with us
being pals um which one are your parents
these are my parents right there john my
dad john
my mother sucks
yeah only me applauding yeah fair enough
you and
you enjoy the red sox i enjoy the red
sox very very very very much really yeah
i'm from uh massachusetts where from
from weymouth weymouth dude i'm from the
w
i thought that w was waltham
what
i'm out of here
it's a great accent jason manzoukis our
friend yes gave me the touchstone to my
own accent my parents my parents
actually have it but uh it's it's the
word burglar burglar burglar burglar two
drug smugglers from everett came in
and they burgled my apartment that's
you're in anyone can do a boston accent
just say burglar yeah that guy's a bro
my parents are here it's boston it's a
bust he's your dad is not happy with you
not happy with you oh no my father my
father and i now swear in front of each
other go ahead we do get out of here my
mother well it's good for yourself right
do you swear in front of your face i
remember my uh
that's not on the card by the way and
you look out you know just the logo
this just reminds me that i'm not on
ellen right now
um
yeah
after uh i remember um after the tragic
events of september 11th
um
television
my dad i was at my dad's house he lives
in uh tewksbury tooke spray and uh
that's up uh up off uh 395 or 128 i
think
uh it's by the donkeys that's uh
not all the way it's past wuben
um
he uh he goes we were looking for food
we're gonna get food delivered he's
looking at the we're looking at menus
and i go what about this it was the best
highest rated restaurant was an afghani
restaurant you guys
afghani
those bastards
oh
what did the appetizers have to do with
it took the terrorists
to to get him to swear in front of me oh
i see but now truck driver
everything
oh really he's letting it out can't stop
swearing